yeah well it's if it didn't exist it
would be way more interesting than
Bigfoot Yeah right everybody's like so
into Bigfoot being real like yeah I
don't get Bigfoot can you talk to me
about that like I do you think what is
what's the concept of Bigfoot I mean I
know okay it's a big hairy guy but yeah
what I mean really come on what is it
most likely there was interaction
between human beings and something
called the Gigantopithecus for thousands
and thousands of years it's a giant
bipedal hominid that existed in Asia
that was between eight and ten feet tall
it was real and it was basically in like
the orangutan family it looks almost
orangutan like but enormous and that was
a real thing okay and they didn't find
out about this until like the 1920s they
found a tooth in an apothecary shop in
China and an anthropologist examined
this tooth it was like where the fuck
did you get this and they they took them
to the site and they dug up more things
and bones and jaw bones and they
determined from the jawbone I'm sorry if
I'm fucking this up scientists but they
determined from the jawbone that they
think it was bipedal that it stood up on
two legs and so then they said well how
big would this thing be and then in the
proportionate yeah I like the feel about
you've seen what one a real one looks
like yeah I just sometimes I when they
say like Oh up in Michigan I'm like is
it really like what are they seeing
bullshit most of the people seeing
shadows and the trees they want to
believe it's Bigfoot there's some bears
that are walking on two legs but if
there was a thing what's really
interesting is that's where it would be
because if it did come across the
layering the the bearing a land bridge
like they believed humans did if that
did happen the many animals met and
navigated from there to here that way
that's where Alaska and the Pacific
Northwest that would be the the natural
path and then if you think about how
densely wooded that area is that would
be a natural habitat for something
that's hiding from people the problem is
you can't hide from shit anymore it's
just another sour they see from space
some something would catch you on a
trail camera some there's trail cameras
they're everywhere they're Fork like did
you see those these guy and his father
got
caught poaching a mother bear in her den
it's you know it's horrific it's
horrible and it's not just horrible
because they they poached this mother
bear in their den and left the babies
essentially to die but they were talking
about how they're not going to get
caught doing it like no one's going to
tie us to this and the way they were
caught there was a 4k camera that was
right behind them that was that was
observing this this whole area where
this bear was dead in they have these
trail cameras now that are incredibly
accurate they're so like it's so
high-definition super clear and the
audios clear they would catch one of
those walking things yeah there was
something out but I think there is
something to be said for the tooth fairy
and thinking we don't know everything
yeah like them's fun the magic of stuff
unknown and behind I mean for me it
doesn't have to be Bigfoot but I love I
love the idea that we haven't seen
everything we don't know everything and
obviously we know that with space and
who knows you know when dimensions and
time and universe but something mythical
is pretty fun well what's interesting is
that there was a bunch of different
kinds of humans that's what's in
training and they found these bones in
Russia that I think they call them the
Denisovans they found a set this is
within the last 10-15 years they found a
completely different species of humans
that lived in Russia they found those
little people on the Isle on a Flores
that was only like ten years ago I mean
there's there's probably dozens more
that they just haven't uncovered
somewhere so if there was at one point
time some big giant hominid it's totally
possible yes don't think you would have
to eat so much to be alive today yeah
beefed it constantly it's like a bear
yeah like you find bear shit everywhere
where's the where's the grill shit yeah
the Bigfoot shit whatever it is it city
is it eating plants is it eating animals
what the fuck is it eating right gonna
eat a lot Oh